(soft thudding)
(snow crunching)
- Welcome everyone. As you can see,
there's a lot of snow in Germany.
This is really a condition that is
pretty much unparalleled for years.
There hasn't been that
much snow here in Germany.
So welcome to another
episode of "Firm Learning."
My name is Heinrich and on my channel
I want to help you to be
successful in the first years
of your career.
Today, we are going to
talk about a question
that is really crucial
for every professional services context.
Doesn't matter if you
wanna talk with colleagues,
with clients, the question often is:
How can you be trusted?
How do you build trust
with your clients and
with your coworkers?
And there is one concept, one framework
that is frequently taught in consulting,
onboarding programs, in training programs
of MBB consulting firms like
McKinsey, BCG, and Bain.
And this is the so-called
"trust equation."
The trust equation.
This is what we're going
to talk about today.
I'm going to explain to you
what the trust equation is all about,
but don't worry I will not
keep it purely theoretical,
but I will give you very tangible advice
on how you can translate
that to your daily work,
on how you can build trust
in your work environment.
And again, it doesn't really matter
whether it's consulting, industry, banking
trust this will be
applicable for many contexts.
So stick in here with me
and let's get started.
So what is the trust equation?
To my knowledge, the trust equation
was first described by David Maister
in his book, "The Trusted Advisor."
It shows a basic relationship
what the factors are that contribute
to you building trust with another person
and more specifically
that the other person actually trusts you.
And according to this equation
there are three factors
that increase trust
but there's also one
factor to reduce trust.
So let's briefly go over these factors
but then later we'll also
provide very tangible examples
on how to make this actionable to you
on what you can do to actually build
and increase trust
according to this framework.
So let's go one by one, credibility.
This is about the knowledge,
are you perceived as
somebody who is credible,
who knows his or her stuff
who really knows what he's talking about.
Second, reliability is
more about your actions.
Can you be trusted
that you will actually do
what you promise to do?
Will you deliver, are you reliable?
Third, intimacy, and
this is about building
a personal relationship, a
bond with the other person.
Does the other person feel
like he or she is close to you?
Of course, a bond helps to
build and develop trust.
And then the fourth
factor, self-orientation
is rather something that reduces trust.
It will hurt you. It will
undermine the relationship
that you are building with a person.
Are you perceived as someone
who only thinks about him or herself?
Can you be trusted that you also
have the other person in mind
or will you do things only to the extent
that they actually benefit you directly?
This is the trust equation and understand
if you not say, hey,
that's a bit theoretic.
What does this really mean for me?
How can I really put this
to life to build trust?
And this is what we
will dig into right now.
And the first factor is credibility.
And this is, indeed, maybe
the most obvious one.
Of course you want to be
perceived as credible.
You want to be perceived
as a domain expert
as a knowledgeable practitioner.
And so in industries like consulting
especially for the most junior colleagues
this can of course be an issue
because often you will be a young graduate
fresh out of university.
How will you be the domain expert
for a certain topic, of a
project that you are staffed on?
So there are a couple of things that I did
when I was staffed as a young colleague
on a project where maybe I
didn't feel too comfortable
about the topic that was being covered.
So the first is fact packs.
In many professional services firms
you will have access to knowledge,
to databases, to industry reports.
Download lots of these, read them
potentially also in your
free time on the weekend.
Make sure that you have
a solid understanding
of all the challenges that
the industry is facing.
And, last but not least,
ask your leadership,
the responsible partners,
to provide a little talk
in the first week of the project.
Often the senior partners
already covered the client
for several years, they really know
the organization inside out
and sometimes they will do
this on their own initiative
but often it also kind of
help just to ask them for it.
And then in most cases, they will be happy
to just spend one or two hours
giving you a download of everything
that they know about the client,
about the topics that are top of mind
of the board members of that client.
And of course this can
be tremendously helpful
for your engagement.
The second element of the
trust formula is reliability.
What can you do so that the client
perceives you as reliable?
And I remember my very
first project at McKinsey
where I got a little
tip from a project lead,
and she told me "Heinrich,
it's actually pretty easy
just on purpose put yourself in situations
where you can prove to the
client that you are reliable."
So next time you sit
together with the client,
tell him or her, okay, I will
send this document to you
until tomorrow 10:00 A.M,
or say, okay, today at
7:00 P.M in the evening,
I will give you a call.
So make these little commitments,
these little promises
and then of course, make sure
that you really fulfill them.
If you commit to give a call at seven
don't call at five past or 10
past seven, but call at seven.
If you promise to send the document
until next day 10:00 A.M,
do that and don't send it at 11:00 A.M.
It is often these little things
that will help you to be perceived
as reliable and trust enough
from my current experiences,
working as a CTO in a
German retail company.
It happens to me every single
day that people tell me
I will call you tomorrow at this time,
I will send you this at this time
and then people don't do that.
This really happens every
day and it drives me crazy
and, of course, this is exactly what leads
to these impressions that
I do not really trust these people,
that I do not find these
people to be reliable.
So don't be like that, but
prove on a regular basis
that you are reliable and this, indeed,
will lead to trust.
The next part of the trust equation
I wanna talk about today is intimacy.
How do you build intimacy with
colleagues, with coworkers,
and we have two tips for you to share.
And the first is a tip that I got
from a former project
lead that I worked with.
And he told me, well, Heinrich,
what you can do is whenever you visit
a client in his office, or now today,
even in a video call, if
you are hanging out on Zoom,
on Teams or whatever,
just look at the things
that are in the office of this person
and ask him or her about that.
Wow, that's an interesting picture.
That's an interesting little statue.
What is it all about?
This is great to build some
intimacy with your client
because this often will spark
some very personal stories,
very personal things that you
will learn from that person.
And the second tip to build intimacy
is really just to share some
personal stories of yours.
Talk about what you do in your free time.
Talk about some hobbies of yours.
Let the other person know
you, open up a little bit.
This, again, will build some
relationships, some bonding.
And of course this often also encourages
the other person to share
something personal as well.
And this is then often the starting point
of a deeper, more intimate relationship
with this colleague or client
that you wanna bond with.
And now the last factor
is self-orientation.
And, again, this is something
that you don't wanna be perceived as.
This is something that will hurt
the trust relationship
that you wanna build.
And this is, indeed, a tricky thing
in many professional services context,
because, of course, the
majority of the people
on the client side that you
work with on an everyday basis,
this is not really the
people that you work for
but you need to work with them
to get something from them
to get some inputs, to get data.
You know, from the
perspective of these people
it's very easy for them to feel used.
They will often and
easily get the perception
that the whole relationship
is a one way street,
that you want to have something from them,
but you do not really care
at all about these guys.
You do not care at all
how he or she is doing,
whether what you are doing is contributing
in any way to her work.
And of course, sometimes
this is hard to avoid
but I found it always very worthwhile,
especially with those
people where you know
that these will be key
contact people for you,
where you know that your project success
will really depend on the relationship
that you will be able to
build with that person.
Make it a point to always also give back.
Do things for this person that
maybe you don't need to do.
Ask this person at the beginning,
hey, what are you working on?
Is there anything I can help with?
Maybe you can help this person
with an analysis that
this person is doing.
Try to do a little favor for this person.
Another problem that often
arises in these contexts
is that especially as a young consultant
you feel like that you
want to put yourself
into the center of attention.
So maybe you were co-creating
a certain result with a client.
Now you want to present something
in front of a senior leader
of that organization.
And here it can often be so
powerful for the relationship
to pre-discuss this with the client
and let the client do
the whole presentation.
Let's make the client the winner here.
Help him or her to shine in
front of his or her leaders.
By this, you will not be
perceived as self-oriented.
This is really one of the best ways
just to build these relationships
and create these situations
where after you've done
something like this
a couple of times then
the client at some point
will also be willing
and happy to potentially
also help you out when
you really need something.
Maybe it will be at some point
where you very urgently need
something from that person.
And then often this person
will also be willing
just to sit there late
at night to create this
on the same day, just to help you.
And of course, just the
opposite might be true
if you're not able to build
this trusting relationship.
So I hope you found these tips insightful.
As always, if you have any question,
just leave me a comment
below in the comment section
and I will do my very best to answer
every single comment that you write.
And as you know, every
comment that you leave
also helps me with the YouTube algorithm,
with the YouTube system, so
this is much appreciated.
And in addition to that
if you took any value
out of this video at all
hit the like button for
the YouTube algorithm.
And of course also
subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
Also I have an Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
There you can see even
more content from me.
Also I have a mailing list linked to that
in the video description.
I now wanna say thanks to all
the members of the channel.
You are really doing a considerable
contribution to my work.
This is much appreciated.
And if you wanna learn about
what it's all about to become a member
and what perks would be in for you,
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
to learn all about this.
So thank you guys. My name is Heinrich.
I release a new video every
single Saturday on this channel.
So cheers, good weekend to
you and talk to you soon.